The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK, settle down.
Settle down.
Let's get started.
So last day we started talking
about diffusion.
Diffusion is a solid-state
mass transport by random
atomic motion.
I made the first point last day
and today I'll make the
second point.
We'll see why it's random
atomic motion.
We reasoned that we
could describe
the ingress of material.
Here I'm showing a concentration
profile.
A profile is nothing more than
a plot of something as a
function of position.
So, this is looking
at, for example,
the doping of a wafer.
This is the free surface
at x equals 0.
As we go to the right,
it represents depth.
And we fix the concentration
at the surface and the
material tails off to zero
deep inside the specimen.
Fick in 1855 annunciated the law
of diffusion, shown here,
that says that the rate of
ingress expressed by the flux
is proportional to the instant
gradient in concentration.
And the constant proportionality
is the
diffusion coefficient.
This is where all the material
science lies.
It's inside the D.
That's what we're going to
talk about more today.
And so we see things tail off
and what we want to do is
figure out what the mathematics
are that'll allow
us to render this thing into a
functional representation.
Because all we know right now
is that we've got something
tailing off.
Ok?
And so this is the gradient
multiplied by the diffusion
coefficient and you can
see that the red line
represents the flux.
The gradient is maximum at the
surface, so the flux is
maximum at the surface.
And as we move farther and
farther into the piece, the
gradient in concentration
becomes less steep, which
means the absolute magnitude
of the flux becomes less
steep, and we go deep inside
where there is no doping yet.
The variation of concentration
is constantly 0, so the slope
is zero, which means
the flux is zero.
So the two sort of track,
one and the other.
And we recognize these are
negative slopes since the
minus sign is here.
Even though we have a
negative slope, we
have a positive ingress.
And then the other thing that
we realized was that the
diffusion coefficient has a
temperature dependence.
And the temperature dependence
looks like this.
It's an exponential of some
kind of a characteristic
energy divided by the product
of -- this is the gas
constant, this is not the
Rydberg constant.
The gas constant is simply the
Boltzmann constant per mole.
So if you take the Boltzmann
constant, multiply it by the
Avogadro number, you get this.
But if you see something times
T, you know it's got to be
either gas constant or
Boltzmann constant.
This two-letter character string
has to have something
akin to a Boltzmann constant,
otherwise you don't end up
with an energy term.
And this in the top is
a barrier energy.
It's a barrier energy to
diffusion and out here we have
the pre-exponential.
Unfortunately we didn't give
it the letter F in honor of
Fick, it's just D naught.
And so there it is.
So if we take this equation and
we plot it, natural log of
d versus 1 over T, that'll
linearize the equation, and we
end up with something that
gives us a straight line.
And the slope is minus Q over
R, where this Q is some kind
of a barrier energy.
And the R is the gas constant
or the Boltzmann constant.
So this is the gas constant.
It's on your table
of constants.
It's got a value in SI units
of 8.314 joules per mole
Kelvin, OK?
Just the Boltzmann times
Avogadro number.
So now I want to invite you
to join me in some pattern
recognition.
If I give you the temperature
dependence of a quantity that
looks like this , in other
words, the logarithm of that
physical parameter versus
1 over T, gives
you a straight line.
You know from the work that we
did on chemical kinetics, this
is the representation
of something that is
an activated process.
Remember the box that would fall
on its side, and it had
to go up on its corner?
So we had some physical sense
of what activation is.
Now this has a log, something
versus 1 over T dependence.
This represents some kind
of an activation energy.
An activation energy.
But what's the activated process
that's going on here?
So that's where I want to take
you into the atomistics.
So here's a cartoon taken from
one of the readings.
And it shows a set of atoms here
and the atom next to the
vacancy wants to move
into the vacancy.
And you can see the artist's
rendition is showing that in
order to get from the current
position into the vacant
position, it's got to squeeze
through this narrow channel.
And it takes energy to move
through that channel.
And there's an activation
barrier
associated with that motion.
Can you see when the atom
is sitting right
at the saddle point?
The system is highly activated
because it's pushing out
against those atoms. And then
finally it falls into the new
slot and the energy drops.
So the activation energy is
associated with moving through
this saddle point.
So what really happens here,
I'll tell you right now.
First of all, we have to
recognize that the system is
depicted there, because it's a
freeze frame, but we know that
above 0 Kelvin, everything
is in motion.
So the only way we can
rationalize what's going on is
to, first of all, recognize
that we
have a pulsating lattice.
We have a pulsating lattice.
Everything's vibrating.
And what's the heartbeat?
What's the idle speed?
I've told you this before.
Everything that's going on in
this room has an idle speed, a
heartbeat, of 10 trillion
times a second.
That's the Debye
frequency, OK?
The idle speed or
the heartbeat.
The heartbeat is called
the Debye frequency.
Here's frequency, lowercase nu,
in honor of Peter Debye.
And it's on the order
of about 10 to the
thirteenth per second.
10 to the thirteenth Hertz.
That's 10 trillion.
So 10 trillion times a second
atoms are going like this.
Pulsating.
All right?
So what has to happen for
that operation to occur?
Well, I've got an atom here,
vacancy next door, but because
it's close packed the atoms
on either side close in.
There's no way this can
squeeze through.
But, imagine, 10 trillion
times a second.
If I'm lucky enough to see the
moment when the atom above
pulsates up, the atom below
pulsates down, a channel can
open up and then this thing
can squirt through.
Now, that doesn't happen
every time.
If it did, history
would have ended.
At 10 trillion times a second,
it's all over for everybody.
Right?
So what happens?
What's the frequency at which
we will get this unique
combination?
It turns out that frequency,
noted gamma, is called the
jump frequency.
That's the jump frequency.
And the jump frequency is on the
order of about 10 to the
eighth Hertz.
10 to the eighth Hertz, which
is about 100 million.
So if you take the ratio of
the Debye frequency to the
jump frequency, you see you get
a value of about one try
in about 10 to the fifth
is successful.
One try in about 10 to the
fifth is successful.
And that explains what's
going on here.
So, what now does that
mean in terms of Q?
What's the breakdown of Q?
Well, clearly, Q, the activation
energy for
diffusion, must involve
both the energy to
form the vacancy --
I'm going to call it delta Hv,
and that's the energy for
vacancy formation --
if you don't have vacancies,
you cannot have motion --
plus the delta H sub
m which is the
energy for atom migration.
So you have to form the
vacancies and then you've got
to squeeze through those
saddle points.
So that's how we get
a sense of it.
And I think I've got
another slide.
OK, so they're I've simply put
the markings on for you so you
can see the atoms above
and below jumping
in the right direction.
That allows the atom on the left
to squirt to the right.
Now, this is also related
to energetics.
It's related to energetics
because the energy to form a
vacancy and the energy to
squeeze through those saddle
points must be related to
the binding energy.
And what else is related
to binding energy?
Melting point.
So, this is an elegant plot
that simply shows that the
energy -- these are all FCC
metals: lead, aluminum,
silver, gold, copper,
and iron.
They're all FCC on
this chart here.
Iron has both BCC and
FCC, but this is
comparing apples to apples.
And you can see that there's
lead melts at 327, aluminum at
660, silver 980,
all the way up.
Iron 1535.
And you can see that the
activation energy for --
that's this Q-value --
the activation energy
for diffusion scales
with melting point.
Again, an indication that this
analysis makes sense.
And then, here's the other
one, the interstitial.
If you have interstitial
diffusion you've got plenty of
interstitials, so you don't
have to pay the penalty to
create the interstitial, but
it's much, much more difficult
to squeeze through
the saddle point.
So, it turns out that activation
energy for
diffusion by interstitial
means is still
fairly highly activated.
So this is in the case
of substitutional
systems, all right?
This is for substitutional.
Substitutional atoms. What
do I mean by that?
An atom that sits on
a lattice site.
If an atom sits on a lattice
site, it has to jump to
another lattice site, which
means there needs to be a
vacant lattice site.
On the other hand, if we're
talking about interstitial
special atoms --
not substitutional atoms,
interstitial atoms --
the assumption is that there's
plenty of interstitial sites.
There are very few systems that
I can think of where the
interstitial sites are so
heavily occupied that this
assumption is invalid.
So in that case, you
don't have to
pay for vacancy formation.
It's simply equal to the
enthalpy, which we know is
analogous to the energy
for a condensed
system of atom migration.
Atom migration gives you the
whole story and it goes back
to the same picture,
and so on.
Now, I said it's random walks,
so let's look at another one.
So, this is an interesting
example.
This is self-diffusion
in cobalt.
Cobalt has a number
of isotopes.
One of them is 59 and
one of them is 60.
60 is a radioisotope.
Cobalt 60 is a radioisotope and
it's used in a variety of
technical endeavors.
And so what we've got here is
a sandwich of cobalt 59 --
cobalt 60 and cobalt 59.
So even though cobalt 60 has
radioactivity and it's got a
different number of neutrons in
the nucleus, chemically it
is identical to cobalt 59,
just as carbon 14 is
chemically identical
to carbon 12.
So there's no concentration
gradient.
Fick's Law says it's
supposed to go by
concentration gradient.
The concentration gradient is
zero across that piece.
And yet if you wait for
long enough, you will
start to see --
the dark atoms here are meant to
represent cobalt 60 in the
sandwich --
after some period of time, the
cobalt 60's will move outward.
And if you wait long enough,
the cobalt 60 concentration
will be uniform throughout
the specimen.
So what's going on?
There's no chemical
concentration gradient, and
yet over time, the cobalt
60 spreads out.
And the answer is this is
happening by random walk.
We've got the pulsating
lattice.
Pulsating lattice.
10 trillion times a second those
atoms are vibrating and
there's going to be
some vacancy.
All of a sudden an atom
falls into a vacancy.
And the mathematics of this --
look at this, this is no
accident -- this curve here
represents something that
looks like a Gaussian
distribution.
At any given time, the amount
of cobalt 60 that's veered
from the center band can be
portrayed by the Gaussian
distribution, the bell curve.
And what's the physical model
for the bell curve?
It's the drunken sailor.
Or I guess I have to be PC.
I'm not going to just
pick on sailors.
Maybe it's the drunken cougar,
the soccer mom
that went out drinking.
OK, so what happens with the
drunken cougar, she comes to
the door, and she starts
to walk, all right?
And then she walks one way or
the other way, until she
finally falls.
And if you go through the number
of steps that it'll
take before the drunken sailor
falls, you get this
distribution.
It's an old physics problem.
The drunken sailor problem.
And it's a normal
distribution.
And that normal distribution
tells you that everything's
going about by random jumping.
Random jumping, according
to this, all right?
So that's why we say
that diffusion is
a random walk problem.
Before I turn this off, I want
you to take a look carefully.
What's wrong with this
textbook cartoon?
Any ideas?
It's a substitutional
system, right?
It's cobalt and cobalt.
This is absolutely impossible.
What's wrong with it?
There are no vacancies.
It's impossible.
There's no vacancies
to jump into.
This thing is jam-packed, so
it's physically unrealistic
from a thermodynamic
standpoint.
There has to be some finite
population of vacancies.
Given this system, there's no
way that the black atom could
jump into the neighboring site,
because you'd have to
have the entire system open up,
and the chances of that
happening are vanishingly
small.
So it just shows you, just
because something costs 150
bucks and is pressed between two
hard covers doesn't mean
it's full of truth, OK?
Be careful here when
you look at this.
So, again, the artist
needed to be guided.
We need to put a few of these
things out, just to give
symbolic recognition to
the fact that we need
to have some vacancies.
OK.
All right, let's keep going.
Let's keep going.
Here is some data.
Various data.
This is diffusion.
This is the logarithm of the
diffusion coefficient
versus 1 over T.
So let's look at the top.
This is hydrogen in iron.
So temperature increases
from right to left.
So, go up, up, up, up, up.
And roughly 900 degrees
Centigrade, iron changes from
BCC to FCC.
And you know from our previous
unit, the number of nearest
neighbors in FCC is greater,
so there's less
void fraction, right?
So that means that it's much
more difficult to move.
And you can see, first of all,
the order of magnitude drop in
the diffusion coefficient, and
also, it's subtle, but the
slope is steeper, because the
activation energy for
diffusion is steeper in a
closer-packed system.
This is carbon in iron.
Same thing.
Relatively gentle slope at the
same temperature, there's a
phase change to FCC and it takes
much, much more energy
per unit increase in temperature
to get the
comparable increase in the
value of diffusion
coefficient.
This is iron, self-diffusion
in iron.
So this would be radio
tracer iron in iron.
Very much lower.
You see these values are up
around 10 to the minus 5, 10
to the minus 6.
This is down to 10 to the minus
11, 10 to the minus 12
centimeters squared
per second.
Iron diffusion changes at the
transition temperature.
Now iron going through
FCC iron.
Here's the last one.
Look at this one.
This is carbon in graphite.
So how does carbon --
suppose I had some
carbon 14 in graphite.
What's the bonding
in graphite?
Silence.
It's covalent.
It's sp2 hybridized.
It's really strong bonds.
The activation energy --
you know, forget just jumping
through that saddle point --
you've got to break those
covalent bonds.
It's very, very high energy
to get carbon to
move through graphite.
And so you see very, very low
values and very, very steep
temperature dependence.
Now, there's another way
to think about this.
Again, this is now looking
at the atomistics.
So this is the same material
trying to indicate that if you
use Fick's Law, moving in from
the surface into the bulk, we
have a certain front.
So this is some isoconcentration
line.
So we could take this value off
of the graph arbitrarily.
So they're saying c
greater than c i.
Because it trails off
to zero, right?
It's asymptotic.
There's no sharp cut-off here.
It trails off.
So what they're doing in that
graph is arbitrarily saying,
let's call this ci.
And where's the front at
concentration ci, given a
constant value of cs
at the surface?
And you can see that there's a
near-constant rate of advance
through the bulk.
But along the grain boundary you
go much, much farther in
the same amount of time.
Why?
Because the atoms in the grain
boundary are not bounded the
same way as the atoms
in the bulk.
There's this gap, this
misalignment.
And so, it's easier to make that
jump, and you can see you
get much, much more advancement
along the grain boundary.
And this is a crack.
And this material covers
the surface.
You get surface diffusion.
Surface diffusion is very
important in many processes,
and it's very fast, because on a
surface, you've got no atoms
on the top.
It's almost liquid-like,
isn't it?
You've got atoms to the bottom,
but you've got no
atoms to the top, so you
can move unconstrained.
Go back to this one.
Imagine here.
Imagine if you didn't have any
atoms on the top, how easy it
would be to make that jump.
All right, let's go and
see what the data are.
Nothing like data.
And I got data for you.
Let's look.
Click, click, click.
All right.
Here's the data.
This is all for the diffusion
of silver.
So I'm going to use this value,
this schematic, and I'm
going to give you the value for
silver diffusion in the
bulk, silver diffusion in the
grain boundary, and silver
diffusion along the surface.
So these are the data.
So this is log diffusion
coefficient versus 1 over T.
Only, I hate this
graph, because
somebody got really wimpy.
You know, it bothers them.
You see, when you plot something
like this, you end
up with, if 1 over T increases
from left to right, this
really means that
high temperature
is over here, right?
1 over T increases this way,
which means temperature is
increasing this way.
So somebody, some weenie, got
all nervous here and put the
numbers backwards, you see?
That way, the high temperature
is over here, but it looks
stupid, because when I see an
activation plot, I want a
negative slope.
It's non-physical to have
a positive slope.
So I condemned this and
I turned it around.
So now let's look at
it the right way.
So this is log d versus 1 over
T, and this is the bulk,
lattice or bulk.
This is grain boundary and this
is surface diffusion, all
in solid silver.
OK, look at this.
First of all --
I'm going to jump from here
-- one, two, three, four.
Four orders of magnitude faster
diffusion along a grain
boundary, which makes sense,
because it's less constrained.
And now let's go from grain
boundary at constant
temperature up to surface.
One, two, three.
Three orders of magnitude
along the surface.
So you can see the effects.
And there's the melting point
of silver, right here.
So at the melting point of
silver, the diffusion
coefficient is about 10 to the
minus 8 centimeters squared
per second, which is the
diffusion coefficient of
virtually every metal at
its melting point.
So I happen to know
that number.
10 to the minus 8 centimeters
squared per second.
Not that I know it as a function
of temperature, but I
know it can't be any
faster than that.
So I said, this is near
liquid-like behavior, what's
the next thing to look for?
Let's get some data from real
liquids and see if this hunch
is correct.
What's the number here?
10 to the minus 5 to 10 to the
minus 4 centimeters squared
per second.
This is diffusion in molten
ferrous alloys.
This is manganese
in molten iron.
10 to the minus 5, 10
to the minus 4.
Bingo.
It really does behave like a
liquid, in terms of diffusion.
Surface diffusion is very fast,
very fast. And it's all
explained by this simple
model of atom jumping.
And I continued it.
Here's data from glasses.
We studied glasses.
So here's a suite of
different glasses.
Log k.
This is permeability, which
is related to diffusion
coefficient.
There's a gas constant in there,
but forget about it.
So this is essentially log of
the diffusion coefficient
versus 1 over T.
We've got a family of lines.
And what's the difference
here?
This is pure fused
silica up here.
SiO2.
There's borosilicate, there's
soda lime, and
there's lead borate.
So what's happening?
We're adding more and
more modifier as we
go from top to bottom.
And as we add modifier, we
break the length of the
silicate network, which means it
packs tighter and tighter,
and as you get tighter and
tighter packing, the diffusion
coefficient gets lower
and lower.
So train your eye.
Let's pick 200 degrees
Centigrade, right here.
So at constant temperature, the
more modifier you put in,
the lower the diffusion
coefficient because things are
more tightly packed.
It's like walking down the
infinite corridor in the
middle of the hour, versus
walking down on the hour.
On the hour, there's
too many people.
It's tighter packing.
And if you're the least bit
civilized, you're going to
have to move a little bit
slower, whereas, if you walk
down the infinite at around
now, no problem.
It's liquid-like behavior.
And now this is the isotherm
at 300 hundred degrees C.
This is from some old
Corning literature.
Corning used to make
glass, at one time.
And this is the logarithm
of diffusivity.
And this is now the set of
silica B203 and P205, and
these are all network
formers, right?
They all form covalent bonds.
So the more silicate, borate,
phosphate you put in, the more
stretched out becomes
the network.
And sure enough, look up here.
See they didn't have names for
their glasses like the Malibu
or the Corvette or something.
They called their glasses
by four-digit numbers.
So someone would say, oh, this
customer needs, oh, I'd sell
them a 7040.
All right?
Because it has a certain
mix of properties.
So forget about what those
numbers are, just know that
this axis indicates that as you
move up, up, up, up, up,
the higher diffusivity is
associated with a much more
open structure.
So, again, a link between
atomistic behavior and
atomistic structure.
It's all there.
OK.
So let's leave that up
there while we go
a little bit forward.
OK, so now, so we've been down
buried at the atomistic level.
Now let's jump up to the
continuum level.
We'll go back to Fick's
first law.
And I want to do something a
little more quantitative.
So I want to look at diffusion
across a permeable membrane.
So this is gas through
a membrane.
Gas through a membrane.
And the membrane
is shown here.
This is the walls
of the membrane.
Membrane has thickness L.
Membrane of thickness L.
In fact, we'll give it a name.
Let's call it membrane.
All right, so here's the
membrane of thickness L, and
I'm going to put gas on the
left at P1, and it's a
constant P1.
So we keep --
we've got a ballast here, so
even though something starts
diffusing, the amount that we
lose doesn't affect the
constant pressure over here.
And on the right side, I'm
going to put a second
pressure, P2.
And just for argument's sake,
I'm going to say that P2 is
less than P1.
So that means we're going to
end up with mass transport
from left to right.
And so, I want to ask, what's
this going to look like if we
use Fick's Law?
And so beneath I'll make a plot,
a concentration profile,
from x equals 0 to x equals L.
And I can morph this
into concentration.
We know the gas law
is PV equals nRT.
This is the gas law.
P is pressure.
V you know is volume.
But I'm going to write all these
out, because some of
these letters are used so many
times that we don't know, is
this the Rydberg constant?
No, it's the gas constant
that you've seen
on the first board.
It's the Boltzmann constant
times the Avogadro number.
T is absolute temperature,
temperature in Kelvins.
And n is not the quantum number,
it's mole number.
Mole number.
PV equals nRT.
And we know that concentration
of i is mole
number of i over V.
Both of those appear in here.
So if you take what's underneath
there, and I'll
expose it in a second, you'll
convince yourself that Ci
equals Pi divided by RT.
And that's how you get that
permeability thing to turn
around as well.
OK, so, I started with gas
pressure, but I'm now going to
write this in terms
of concentration.
So I'm going to morph P1 into C1
and over here, P2 into C2.
And I want to plot
the profile.
So what's the profile
look like?
I'm going to plot the profile
at steady state.
At steady state.
At steady state, after I've
waited a while, I have a
straight-line profile across
here, at steady state.
It's pinned at the two ends.
It's pinned at the two
ends and varies
continuously across here.
And you can see from Fick's
Law, that if you have a
situation in which the gradient
is invariant across
the piece, the gradient is --
dc by dx is the same here, as it
is here, as it is here, as
it is here. dc by dx is
invariant, right?
It doesn't change.
This is a straight line.
Well, if dc by dx is invariant,
and d is a
constant, then J is invariant,
which just means
no sources are sinks.
All of the material that
goes in, must come out.
This means that J is not
a function of time.
J is invariant.
J is not a function of time.
I come back here ten
minutes later, I
have the same profile.
That's what steady
state means.
That's what study state means.
OK, and then, of course, if I
wanted to be a little bit
pedantic, I could say, in
certain systems, the diffusion
coefficient is a function
of concentration.
So, when the diffusion
coefficient is a function of
concentration, then even at
steady state, you might have
some bowing of the profile,
but that's a
little bit more advanced.
OK.
So, I can describe everything
that's going on here.
If I wanted to know how much
material leaves from inside
over a certain period of time,
then I can simply say that
total material lost is given by
Fick's first law when you
have steady state.
It's simply going to equal the
product of the flux, which is
mass per unit area per
unit time times the
area times the time.
And that's sort of analogous
to Faraday's Law, right?
If I wanted to look at how much
electrical charge I get
for a certain period of time
with current passing, I could
say that the total charge is
the product of the current
times the time.
You know this relationship.
Well, can you see that J times A
is analogous to the current?
It's the mass current.
It's mass flow rate.
Mass flow rate per unit area
times area gives me something
that's analogous to the current,
and the time is the
time, this is the total material
lost, this is the
total electrical charge.
These two are the comparable
equations.
OK.
Now, I want to go to the more
sophisticated question, and
that is, what happens
before steady state?
Before steady state
is achieved?
Suppose at time zero, the
membrane has no gas in it.
And at time zero, I inflate
the left side.
And just to keep things
simple, I'm going to
set c2 equals 0.
It's a linear equation.
You can always add it, but I
just want to keep it simpler
for the analysis.
So, suppose at t equals 0, we
inflate to c1 on the left side
of the empty membrane.
There's nothing in
the membrane.
So, let's see what happens.
First, I'm going to solve
the problem graphically.
Because we know what's
going to happen.
I'm going to have to
do the mathematics.
So, here's what we expect.
This is going from 0 to L.
And we've got nothing in the
membrane on both sides, so
that's good.
And then, at time zero,
I inflate to c1.
There's nothing in here.
So, what do I have?
Well, I know if I wait long
enough, it's eventually going
to look like this.
Because that's the steady
state solution.
I've put here c2 equals
0, for simplicity, but
we can change it.
It's a linear equation.
We can just add.
So, what happens
at time 0 plus?
I start getting diffusion in
from left to right, following
Fick's Law.
So it's going to look
like this, isn't it?
This is the approach
to steady state.
Some books will call it
nonsteady state or unsteady.
Unsteady to me means unsteady,
so I refuse to use those
terms. I call this
the transient.
That's the literary term.
The transient.
We're talking about the approach
to steady state.
And in some systems, you never
get to steady state.
But that's OK.
So here's what it's going to
look like at some very, very
short time afterwards.
It's going to look like that,
only somewhat modified for
this geometry.
So it's going to look
like this, isn't it?
It's pinned at c1, and it's
pinned at 0, and it varies
continuously.
So this is at time t 1.
What happens at time t 2?
At time t 2, it advances
a little bit farther.
But in all instances, the slope
and the shape is given
by this, Fick's first law.
So this is at time t 2.
And let's do one more.
Three's a charm.
So, let's take a green one.
All right, so here's at t 3,
still pinned at c 1 and still
pinned at 0.
So this is at t3.
And then finally, this
is steady state.
So if we park at any place --
let's park at x1.
Watch here.
Can you see that the slope
at t1 is gentle?
The slope at t2 is
steeper than t1.
The slope at t3 is steeper
than t2, and this is the
highest. So, we go from nothing,
to gradual, gradual,
gradual, until we finally
reach steady
state, and we stop.
And then at that point, we just
continue to have to mass
flowing through.
And look, the concentration is
zero, but the flux is not
zero, because the flux isn't
related to the concentration.
It's related to the
concentration gradient.
Zero concentration,
but non-zero
concentration gradient.
In fact, just for grins and
chuckles, I could plot the
ascent of this.
I could plot time
at x equals x1.
I could plot J.
And what's J?
At time zero, it's zero.
Then it's small, then it's
larger, larger, larger
asymptotically.
And this is J of steady state.
And this is t1, t2, t3.
That's the approach
to steady state.
And you might say, well,
this is kind of
a professor's pedantry.
It's not!
This is doping of
semiconductors.
You don't run processes
at equilibrium.
You run them far from
equilibrium.
So in the transient mode,
doping, outgassing, drying,
what have you.
So, now I want to give
you the shape of the
concentration profile.
So how do I do that?
OK, so the shape of the
transient profile is not given
by Fick's Law.
The Fick's Law just gives
me the gradient.
In other words, here's
what I want.
I want C as a function of
x at any given time.
That's what I want.
I want to be able to
plot the profile.
So, profile is C of x, but
C of x varies with time.
So, I need C of x at
different times.
What gives me that?
What gives me that is
Fick's second law.
Go to FSL, Fick's second law.
Now, Fick's second law, I'm just
going to put it up here.
I'm going to show you
the solution.
I don't expect you
to solve it.
I would, you were all required
to have differential equations
as a pre-req, but you don't.
So, I'm just going to put it
up here so that you see it.
It's a partial differential
equation, and
it looks like this.
And it's really beautiful.
It's got a beautiful symmetry
and the fonts look great, so
that's why we put it up here.
So, this is the partial in
time goes as the double
derivative in space, because
we need a two-variable
function, right?
We want x and t.
And this assumes that the
diffusion coefficient is not a
function of concentration.
If it is, the equation
is messier.
This assumes a constant
diffusion coefficient.
So, this, as you can see, is a
partial differential equation,
which is a bummer, because it's
hard to solve, all right?
But, it's linear.
It's a linear partial
differential equation, which
means the solutions
are additive.
We know this already
from LCAOMO.
So, I can handle, because I can
solve it once and then I
can give you ways to patch
it, to make it useful.
So, the solution.
First of all, how do I
specify this fully?
Every time you differentiate
--
I'm going to give you some
math here, real math
that you can use.
When you differentiate, you
throw away information, right?
The derivative of a
constant is zero.
So, what was the value
of the constant?
It's gone.
You lost it.
So you have to bring it back.
So when I double derivative
this, I need two pieces of
spacial information.
And when I take a derivative
with respect to time, I need
one piece of temporal
information.
That's math.
All the other lemmas and
postulates, forget them.
This is how you use
it, all right?
So, I need two pieces of spatial
information and one
piece of temporal information.
So these specify our boundary
conditions, right?
So, what are our boundary
conditions.
So, I will need the
concentration of
all x at time 0.
That's this.
The answer to this question.
And what we're going to do is
say that it's a constant.
I don't know what the constant
is, it could be zero, it could
be any arbitrary number, but
I'm going to give you the
solution for the situation
in which the initial
concentration is a constant.
So, you could look at this and
say, well, what happens if
it's a non-zero constant?
You ready for linearity?
Watch this.
This is how cool linearity is.
You see this set of solutions?
This is the set of solutions
for C equals 0.
What if C equals some
non-zero value?
I just shift the origin down to
here to the non-zero value
and everything sits there.
That's what superposition
gives you.
That whole set of solutions
just gets jacked up by the
value of C naught.
If C naught is 0, this slams
down onto the x-axis.
That's real math.
You're the master.
The math is the slave. Never
let math enslave you.
I won't.
I refuse.
So that's how you make C
equals C naught work.
And then you have to peg the
concentration at the surface.
I can give you examples where
that's not the situation,
where you have a variable
concentration at the surface.
The solution I'm going to give
you won't work for those.
So, x equals 0 is the surface.
So, at x equals 0 at all time, I
have some fixed value, which
I'm going to just
call C surface.
And I need a third boundary
condition.
And the third boundary
condition is a
mathematical trick.
We're going to say that this
only works at short times.
It's called the short time.
And at short times, I'm
going to say that --
from the perspective of the
diffusion experiment --
at very, very short times,
this sample appears to be
infinitely long.
Because the amount of material
that goes in doesn't hit the
other side.
So, at very, very short times,
we can pretend that it's
semi-infinite.
And so then we can write that
the concentration --
this is the short time, which
means infinite size, and
you'll see that the
two are related --
that the concentration at
infinity, then, doesn't change
from the initial value.
The concentration at infinity
for all time must equal the
initial value C naught.
And so if you put these three
boundary conditions into that
equation, you end
up with this.
This is the thing.
You get C minus Cs over
C naught minus Cs.
This is surface concentration.
This is initial concentration.
This is C.
It varies by this amount.
Error function of x over 2 times
the square root of Dt.
So, you tell me the time and I
can tell you the relationship
between concentration
and position.
Now I've got to tell you what
the error function is.
Here's the error function.
This is this problem before.
This is the solution I'm
going to show you.
Here's Cs.
Here's C naught.
The most general case.
C naught could be zero.
And this curve here is given
by this equation, OK?
And this is an example
of doping, isn't it?
This is how doping would work.
And this is the case where C
s is greater than C naught.
If we turn it around and we make
the surface concentration
less than the initial
concentration, we'll get the
complementary situation.
The complementary situation
looks like this.
So in this case, C naught is up
here, Cs is down here, and
we end up with this.
So now matter is going
out, because Cs
is less than C naught.
So this is --
what do you want to call it --
this is effusion, this is some
kind of a drying process,
outgassing.
And this is doping.
And what's the shape
of this curve?
The shape of this curve.
ERF.
That's what math is.
You find a mathematical
function that
templates for the curve.
And ERF, I'm going to show you,
is related to random walk
statistics.
So, it's physically validated.
It's the best fit.
I mean, heck, if you find
anything that is pinned at two
ends and has curvature, you'll
get a reasonable fit, but
what's the right fit?
The right fit is this.
The error function
looks like this.
Here's the error function.
Error function.
I'm going to plot ERF of
z as a function of z.
And it goes from 0 to 1.
It looks like this.
All right?
And here's an error
function table.
Those are exact values.
And it turns out that ERF
is pretty much linear up
to about point 6.
Up to about point 6.
ERF of point 6 not to less
than about 1% is point 6.
And then as you go farther and
farther out, and eventually,
ERF of infinity equals 1.
But you don't even need tables
for 0 up to point 6.
And you can push it, go to
point 6, 5, if you want.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's push harder.
6, 5.
It's linear.
You don't need tables.
Right?
And so ERF of 0 equals 0.
Oh, let me give you
the function.
You know how you can
define sine?
Sine is that integral of
something over 1 minus blah,
blah, blah?
We've got a definition
for this one, too.
It's cool.
Here's what the error
function looks like.
ERF of z equals the integral
from 0 to z of e to the minus
u squared du.
You might say, why is he
showing us all of this?
Because he wants to torment
you, that's why.
No, it's because I'm trying
to teach you something.
What's e to the minus
u squared?
Actually, I think I can squeeze
it in right there.
What's e to the minus
u squared du?
This function here, that's the
bell curve, isn't it? e to the
minus u squared.
That's this thing.
It's symmetric, right?
It's a minus u squared, so
it doesn't matter if u is
positive or negative.
And e to the 0 was 1, and
then back and forth.
And so what this is doing, is
it's integrating from zero out
to some value.
That's all.
That's the random walk.
This is the drunken sailor.
How far does the drunken
sailor go?
That's the shape of this
curve, the integral.
And we'd like it to be so that
if you integrate from zero to
infinity, the area
will be one.
It turns out that this area
here is root pi over 2.
So, therefore, to normalize,
we put 2 over root pi.
That's how you get the
error function.
All right?
So, the integral from zero to
zero is zero, and the integral
from 0 to 1 is going to be,
whatever it is, point 8, 4, et
cetera, et cetera.
So, that's it.
That's it.
Now we have the functional
relationship to describe any
of these curves.
And you'll get some practice
in doing that.
And it's a lot of fun.
Because now you can talk about
how long it's going to take to
dope something, and so on.
Outgassing.
And now I'm going to show you
something really cool, and I'm
not kidding you.
This has served me well.
I've been here 30 some odd
years, and I've been in
consulting situations where I
can, in my head, figure out
order of magnitude of what it's
going to take to run a
diffusion problem.
Because you've got, up here, C
minus Cs over C naught minus
Cs equals ERF error function
of x over 2 roots of Dt.
So, this runs from 0 to 1.
The right side.
When I went to school, the left
side of the equation had
to do the same thing as the
right side of the equation.
So if the right side of the
equation runs from 0 to 1, the
left side of the equation
runs from 0 to 1.
So, let's pick a -- are
you ready -- average
value from 0 to 1.
What would you pick?
I'd pick point 5.
Now, I don't have to go to the
error function tables because
point 5 is less than point 6.
So ERF of x over 2 root Dt is
essentially equal to x over 2
roots of Dt.
So, now I've got one half equals
one half x over root
Dt, from which I can say that
x is approximately equal to
the square root of Dt.
And I can be sitting in a
meeting and someone says, gee,
I don't know how long
it's going to take.
This thing's going to go
down about 100 microns.
And how long is it
going to take?
So, I pick a number, like, OK,
if this is 100 microns, and
this thing here is 10 to the
minus 8, now you just take the
square root of that, and tell
them, oh, it's going to take
so many minutes, and
they go, huh?
How did you get that?
It's right there.
And I'm not trying to tell
them a number for three
significant figures.
They just want to know is it
going to take a minute, an
hour, a day, or are we
out of business?
And you can make that
calculation with this.
This is so powerful.
And everything I told you about
diffusion applies to
conductive heat transport.
You can do the same thing for
heat transfer, figure out how
long it's going to take
for a wave to go in.
This is really powerful stuff.
Anyway.
Let's move on.
Well, there's our pal.
OK, so I was going to give you
the last element today.
The last element.
Remember, we talked
about clean air.
So, I'm showing you the
catalytic converter.
That's this thing here,
coated with platinum,
rhodium, and so on.
And I'm showing you the
electronic control module.
That's the CPU.
It's a little bit toned down
from a Pentium, but it
certainly started from
one of these units.
So, we've studied all of this.
Right?
OK.
And, so now, I want to talk
about this piece here, the
oxygen sensor. why do we
need an oxygen sensor?
Remember, the last day I told
you that to get rid of NO, the
NOx, you have to reduce, And to
get rid of CO and unburned
hydrocarbons, you
have to oxidize.
Well, you have to pick.
You can't have two different
atmospheres in the same place
at the same time.
Turns out there's a
lucky sweet spot.
Can you see that the conversion
efficiency is high
for both reduction and oxidation
reactions if you peg
the air-to-fuel ratio at 14.6.
So you can't just set the
carburetor or the fuel
injectors at some arbitrary
ratio, because as you change
humidity, as you change
temperature -- what happens
when the temperature
goes down?
How much oxygen is
there in the air?
It's still 20%, but
PV equals nRT.
You ever try barbecuing
when it's --
I mean, I don't know, maybe
you're not from the Northeast.
But if you want to barbecue
when it's 0 Fahrenheit?
Do you think you get a hotter
fire or a colder fire?
How much oxygen is there
per unit volume in cold
air versus warm air?
Think about it.
It'll be on the next exam.
I'm just kidding.
OK.
So, anyway, here's the sweet
spot that gives you both
oxidation and reduction.
And so we need a
feedback loop.
That feedback loop is provided
by the oxygen sensor.
Dave, would you mind cutting
to the document camera?
So this is an oxygen sensor
that's used on automobiles.
Here's the plug.
This goes into the pin set.
And the oxygen sensor is
inside this housing.
This housing, you can see --
OK, what I'm going to
show you is what's
going on inside here.
This has got all kinds of
protective stuff on it so that
it doesn't get dented during
installation and so on.
But it sits inside the
exhaust train.
It sits inside the
Now, may we go back to
the slides, please?
Every car that's running a
catalytic converter has to
have one of those in order to
control, right here, to make
sure the air-to-fuel
ratio is optimum.
Otherwise, the catalytic
converter is either not doing
a good job on NOx, or it's
not doing a good job on
hydrocarbons and whatever
the other thing is.
Anyway, so here's what
it looks like.
So, this is what's inside.
It's a closed, one-end tube
made of zirconia.
Zirconium oxide.
And zirconium oxide conducts
oxide ions.
And there are platinum
electrodes on the
front and the back.
And what I showed you
was from this side.
And this is the exhaust gas
going along here, and this is
the edge of your
exhaust train.
And two wires coming off of
that sensor go to the CPU.
The CPU measures voltage and
then from there, it regulates
the air-to-fuel mix to the
engine, to the exhaust gas,
and around and around and around
we go, so that when
exhaust gas gets to the
catalytic convert, it is
optimally being converted.
So, we want to get
fast response.
We don't want slow response.
And it's a solid-state sensor
and solid-state diffusion is
slow, but that's we
have to rely upon.
So we add a dopant.
We add a dopant to zirconia
to stabilize its crystal
structure and create more oxygen
vacancies to get faster
diffusion and a shorter
response time.
So what we add is calcia, one
of the candidates, and it
creates oxygen vacancies, and
these oxygen vacancies allow
us to get more rapid
response time.
So, these oxygen vacancies
compensate for the charge
imbalance, thanks to the
addition of calcia.
So, it's an engineered
material.
Without this it doesn't
work, all right?
And so, now what I've shown you
is that on the basis of
this oxygen sensor, we can
monitor the exhaust gas flow
so as to optimize the conversion
here in the
catalytic converter and do so by
sending information to the
CPU on the car.
And the number one consumer
of CPU's is the automobile
industry, because every car
has at least one, if not
multiple, CPU's.
So this is a good example of how
understanding the lessons
of solid state chemistry can
allow us to build fuel
efficient automobiles that have
minimum toxic emissions
to the environment.
All right, we'll see
you on Monday.